so this is a conversation where I want
to see what you think I'm not suggesting
I know what needs to happen I'm not
suggesting any authoritarian tactics by
States I just want to see where you're
at on this issue coronavirus is
exploding at the national level some
states are doing well but when you look
at the United States as a country in
total our worst for days in the United
States in terms of new cases came in the
last five days so you go to the very
beginning of the pandemic the four worst
days in terms of new cases have all
happened in the last week and yet here
in Massachusetts we I'm so thrilled to
say we reported zero deaths yesterday
for the first time since the pandemic
started and in fact New England and New
York and New Jersey this sort of eight
state consortium these are some of the
best places to be right now in terms of
the the degree of reduction in cases and
transmission Vermont had no new cases
yesterday New Hampshire had only 22
Maine had only 34 as I said
Massachusetts zero deaths in about a
hundred new cases Connecticut about 150
New York and New Jersey still with
higher case numbers but dramatic
reductions and again relative to their
population the numbers are not quite so
scary so in terms of the consortium our
governor Charlie Baker here has expanded
the no quarantine bubble to include New
York for example now you're gonna be
able to if you travel from New York to
Massachusetts you're not going to be
required to quarantine for 14 days
assuming you meet certain requirements
masks are everywhere as many of you know
I've been in Martha's Vineyard this week
people everybody's just wearing masks
you go everywhere it's mask mask masks
you're not going anywhere and seeing
people without them but look at what's
happening elsewhere you've got these
huge swaths of red states plus
California which are seeing record cases
you've got California Texas Florida
Arizona Georgia the Carolinas Tennessee
Louisiana Alabama Ohio and at some point
you're only going to keep that walled
off for so long at some point if the
case is
keep exploding in certain parts of the
country the cases will start going up
here in the Northeast you you have
flights between these parts of the
country so-called mandatory quarantines
are really tough to enforce and people
know it people aren't doing it so does
the Northeast need to do something
because we're hopefully looking at being
able to safely open schools in the fall
and do more but if the cases start
bleeding over from the more disastrous
parts of the country it's going to ruin
the work we've been doing for months at
this point again reminder I played this
clip earlier I'll play it again doctor
foul he is talking about 100,000 new
cases a day in the u.s. if things don't
turn around
he says the infection rate is out of
control in some parts of the country
take a look at this clip one more time
it is going to be very disturbing I will
guarantee you that because when you have
an outbreak in one part of the country
even though in other parts of the
country they're doing well they are
vulnerable I made that point very
clearly last week at a press conference
we can't just focus on those areas that
are having the surge it puts the entire
country at risk we are now having
40-plus thousand new cases a day I would
not be surprised if we go up to a
hundred thousand a day if this does not
turn around and so I am very concerned
so what should the Northeast do I mean
legally this is difficult the
Constitution grants ingress and egress
to and from States and I am not
proposing that we violate the
Constitution airlines have shown they
are committed to having more flights and
having flights be more full so I don't
know what if anything can be done but if
cases continue to explode to this degree
in some parts of the country
eventually the pandemics going to come
back to the Northeast because people are
traveling people are ignoring quarantine
can you do roadblocks but not to stop
people from coming in merely to register
that they are coming in and ask them
where will you be quarantine you still
can't really enforce it you don't have
the resources but maybe if people go
through that they would be more mindful
and maybe be more likely to stick to the
required quarantine I don't know it's
obviously beyond the resources of any
state to really enforce it so I have no
idea my question to you is what should
be done we are beyond the early hotspot
phase the early hotspot phase was based
on flights and and the earlier spots of
contagion you had hot spots it's now
based on policy the places with the
better policy are doing better the
places with the looser policy are doing
worse what should be done should the
Northeast do anything let me know what
you think and we'll have more coverage
of this on our Instagram page at david
pakman show make sure you're following
us there